publicité impôts faire part à temps ses
voyages dîners ça d'ailleurs
moi je sais pas je ramène la tulle pas
te plains pas moi j'y vais seul à être
horrible tout le monde y va pour
célébrer l'amour moi j'y vais en tant
que bons gros ce célibataire des
familles attendent-ils plus triste que
ça sérieux donc les morts pendant que
les vraiment mort non mais c'était un
grand-oncle et plus je connaissais pas
vraiment vraiment j'avais l'enterrement
savent en tant que maire à tort je peux
venir avec toi on parle bien de
l'enterrement la suisse parce que
personne ne meurt dans ma famille quel
dommage mais c'est dommage de coups je
suis jamais allé en interne en sera
l'occasion à tence pas les visas c'est
juste des vieux qui chialent dans une
église
et justement faut que je vois ça elle te
plaît dit oui d'accord
yes trop bien tu n'es pas comme on a
tout tué différentes
[Musique]
être adulte c'est aussi accepter la mort
à quoi dans le temps de faire un petit
effort vestimentaire je vois tu m'a pas
dit qu'ils avaient un dress code
et puis c'était pas manquer sur le
player donc ça va comment je te présente
je vous rencontre enfin vous êtes encore
plus belle que je ne pensais c'est
martin la maman de cyprien enchanté
nathalie nathalie mais c'était pas
l'horizon mais alors l'oreille déjà
c'est pas ma femme c'est ma petite amie
a pu venir parce qu'elle travaille mais
je suis avec nathalie une amie je suis
désolé pour des comptes ça fait sept ans
qu'il avec sa chérie me l'a jamais de
présenter de sérieux comme ça au hasard
ça c'est qu'on va finir par croire qu'il
l'a inventé un os et comme ton tour
daniel là on me disait qu'il avait des
femmes en veux tu en voilà
on se tue ils étaient tous aller très
bien bon je vais vous laisser discuter
entre vous dans notre fille
moi je fais un tour donc comment ça se
passe bien buffet des petits fours j'ai
un peu la belle bonjour mon fils on peut
sache que je suis de tout coeur avec toi
bon pour l'ordre j'ai d'abord pensé à
faire passer ta grand mère
ensuite la chanson ton donc et pour
finir toi et ton discours en discours
daniel ce n'est pas un au revoir c'est
un à bientôt et même à très bientôt
c'est super plaisant thermique c'était
très émouvant
merci pour tout ça à denise avant
d'écouter le petit neveu de daniel
cyprien jan ove nous allons tous
ensemble cyprien écouter de la musique
pour qu'ils se tiennent prêts mieux
tomber
cette chanson sur laquelle daniel a
voulu nous dire au revoir c'est end of
the line du groupe ou un dodge ford
à baden
[Musique]
daniel un tonton daniel comme je
l'appelais mon tonton
non c'est le tonton de ma mère tonton
daniel tu oublies ray jamais quand tu
joues billy ray jeux de toi je
n'oublierai jamais je mets toi enfin
désolé en fait je j'avoue je ne connais
pas grand chose surtout pour daniel si
quelqu'un veut faire un discours son
tour daniel rappeler quelques souvenirs
de l'époque il te prendre la place
dac en fait à part mami a personne qui
peut parler de sony allait enfin dispo
et encore j'ai recopié discours que j'ai
fait pour le 17 mars à ok tonton daniel
c'était quelqu'un de très secret un
petit peu comme nous tous dans cette
famille on voit compris je suis passé de
la pudeur ou d'aller acheter un petit
peu des deux j'imagine tout cas j'ai
appris plein de choses sur toi
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus quand 27 ans
j'appelle j'appelais cyprien partie
grâce à toi j'ai appris que tu écoutais
windows ford sont mes groupes préférés
aussi je me disais que on se connaissait
pas très bien que ce n'était pas grave
est en fait aujourd'hui je me dis que
c'est un peu dommage on serait bien
entendu je pense au revoir ton agnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pensez que je peux conduire minivan
corbières ebit s'était très bien si pis
alors entrevoit camp avant noël
j'imagine en fait je vous disais comme
l'aurait la semaine prochaine elle elle
travaille pas donc peut-être que tu
passe chez moi qui mets présentés
non mais je dis ça enfin je vous
préviens si si ça me ferait très plaisir
cyprien
[Musique]
c'était trop bien géré on n'est qu'un dj
à mon enterrement alors plein de bougies
comme ça parce que c'est trop beau
maintenant tu pouvais laisser les
bougies le pensais pas je les payais jeu
lacombe
[Musique]